okay hi angela
hi steve how are you
great how are you good thanks
you know it is amazing all this
technology i don't even know where you
live
where are you located
right i live in upstate new york it's a
town called wappingers falls probably
never heard of it never heard of it
okay so here we are at sort of the
opposite ends of the continent here
and we're able to talk and we got a
video cam going and we're going to talk
about language learning and you've been
learning spanish right how long have you
been learning spanish
let's see
i actually first started spanish in high
school
so that would be
let's see
20 years ago 19
okay
we won't do we won't do the math on that
yeah so
right
quite some time off and on of course
and of course you're you're learning
spanish at link
i hope you're enjoying it
it's yes i am
no way i'd still be
at link if i weren't right
but you sometimes express the sort of
concern or
frustration might be too strong a word
but that you feel you're not progressing
as much as you would like or sometimes
you seem to feel you're not progressing
at all or
explain that
like what would you like to be achieving
that you're not achieving
right well i think that
my i want to be fluent right which are
already is a kind of
nebulous term i guess right
um
but
when
i have conversations with the tutors
they're always very complimentary they
say wow your spanish is great it's
improved a lot but i just feel myself
stumbling
and because i know it's not i don't
think that it's
really
a real
live situation you know i mean right i
kind of
feel that i couldn't really
make it in that kind of
situation where i had to speak the
language right
right because and then i've had a couple
of times where i've had to like just for
um to order something in a restaurant
and i've kind of
you know
gone a little bit blank and not been
able to say anything and that's kind of
frustrating for me right
okay uh do you find that when you're uh
reading stuff or listening to stuff uh
link that you understand more now than
you did say six months ago
yeah definitely right definitely yeah i
mean
i i don't find that
like i maybe have different expectations
than you you know i've been studying
russian now for four years at link i
certainly understand much more than i
did even a year ago
but when i was recently in russia where
i the higher the degree of tension
the less well i do so if i'm in a lineup
say at the train station and there's
eight people behind me
and i get there and i ask you know where
do i buy a ticket or when are the trains
to such and such and back comes the
answer rapid fire
and i didn't understand it although i
know all the words but there's pressure
and there's people behind me and she's
impatient
uh you don't do as well whereas if
you're surrounded by friends like we
went out with some of our link members
for dinner 10 people and
everybody's a friend
so
you know you do well because you're
supported you're comfortable so i think
some of those things i think
influence it and when you're talking on
skype with a tutor even though i think
we are good friends with our tutors i
know i am with my russian tutors i'm
sure you are with your spanish tutors
it's still it's skype it's not the same
as sitting around a coffee table so i
think some of these things influence how
we do
true enough that's true yeah
i don't know and the other thing i feel
is that um
like i i enjoy the process
of of listening and reading and hearing
the language and saying wow look at me
i'm listening to all this in russian i
understand it
you know i try to i tend to pat myself
on the back a lot more and yeah i
stumble i know i make mistakes when i
speak
i know that i stumble looking for words
some things i can express quite
comfortably and other things i can't
seem to get i've painted myself into a
corner i can't seem to
no matter which word i look for it
doesn't i can't kind of explain what i
want to explain
i just think that's part of the process
whereas if you were to go have you ever
been to a spanish speaking country
yes i have where were you
i i've been to several i've been to
these are all on vacation right so for
you know five or six days
mexico costa rica honduras
how did you how did you do down there
okay
i
was able to get my point across when i
had to
i wasn't as fluent as i would like but i
i was okay i survived
i didn't speak spanish
all the time right my friends or my
husband with me
don't speak spanish so i you know
didn't speak it all the time but it was
it was
good
did you more or less yeah
did uh did the people down there speak
english or or did they not speak english
um right well it depends and close uh
let's see in honduras that was where i
spoke the most spanish because people
were
i was they really didn't speak english
at all
so i really had to speak spanish and i
think that's where i spoke the most
spanish and i didn't feel that bad
because
um they wouldn't be able to understand
me speaking english anyway so
my stumbling spanish was better than
you know not doing anything
but uh in mexico we went to cancun right
and everyone there speaks english right
because it's a big tourist place
so
did they were they
identifying you as an american would
they immediately switch to english yes
of course yeah that's that can be a bit
frustrating too right they're not
they're they want to speak english and
they want to show that they speak
english and so they immediately succeed
which is a bit deflating which is a bit
deflating at times
yeah
but uh steve i think that i
you keep saying this thing about the
process i think it's because you've
learned so many languages
that you're able to really trust that
process
you know where i'm still with my first
language is what i'm doing really
working i'm not sure so i'm kind of
impatient when is it going to happen
i think that really comes into play also
yeah um
yes
and i mean in my own case the first
language that i really went after was
french
and to be honest it wasn't until i went
to france
that i really kind of
you know
became weightless so to speak went into
outer space you know because
it's it's it's a long process so in a
way i feel you know you're building
yourself up to
to where you can take advantage of a
situation where you're going to be
speaking the language for two three four
months whatever until you're in that
situation sort of immersed in the
language
uh you're not going to make that
spectacular breakthrough you know
because you're not speaking that much so
you're building up your vocabulary your
familiarity with the language
so that if you then go if you were to go
to honduras let's say you would you went
down there on an aid project or
something you know and you're going to
spend two months in a village helping
people build a clinic or something that
people do these kinds of things
uh there would be a big breakthrough
whereas if you didn't have the
basics if you didn't have that language
potential then you wouldn't be able to
take advantage of it as much
i kind of see it that way that if you're
not speaking that much you won't be able
to speak that well
you know at some point you have to have
a lot of
situations where you're forced from
morning to night to speak the language
if that makes sense
like i found it makes sense
i'm trying to see a way around it but i
don't you know i mean for example
chinese which i studied a lot and stuff
i think my trips to china where for two
weeks i'm speaking chinese for morning
till night
those have a big influence on me
but i wouldn't be able to speak chinese
from morning to night if i hadn't worked
at it ahead of time right
so
yeah
so at some point yeah
you can only do so much and so far as
the speaking is concerned until you get
yourself in a switch situation you just
have to be confident that you are in
fact building up the capability
so that if you went to honduras like if
you were to go to some place where
everyone spoke spanish on a two-month
study program or something then i think
you'd come back from that speaking the
way you would like to speak right until
you do that you won't achieve that level
so therefore you kind of have to be
happy with the level that you have
right
and i am happy when i'm able to
you know read a book or watch a program
on tv or
for example we have i have a meetup
group here right where i am
and they speak spanish and i'm able to
understand them and sometimes i
interject so
that that's all good that's a good idea
are they they're like native speakers
yeah well there are
we're pretty small right now
so there are two of us that are not
native speakers right there are five
that are native speakers but that's
great that's a great
opportunity the trouble with all these
things is whether it's your meetup group
or
talking on skype with one of our tutors
it only amounts to a half hour an hour
here or there right
when you're in a situation where you're
speaking from morning till night with
you with people
say you went on a trip with nothing
but spanish speakers i mean that degree
of intensity it's just it just turns a
switch
that's that's been my experience
so i
tried that my well you know me being a
little bit kind of shy i tried it you
know just talking to myself but i guess
it's not the same and i just felt really
kind of silly document
you know i hear these people who talk
themselves or they do this shadowing
talking while listening and stuff
i find that i can do that a little bit
and then i just stop doing it it's just
it's just not not the same but we had
like
we've had you know
chinese for example i went there when my
book was published in china i had to go
there on two separate occasions and my
publisher i was with
their people like every day we were
traveling around uh giving lectures in
chinese i had to prepare my lecture in
chinese it was like solid chinese and so
you do that for a week and you just you
just bumped up a whole you know level
so you kind of have to set up that kind
of an experience
yeah all right well that's interesting
um
i think the main thing is that we enjoy
what we're doing
you know
so i i feel that the goal is the process
in a way
so i i look forward every day to
downloading
my interviews from this russian radio
station and i listen to them and i read
them and then i save them say words and
phrases in lincoln i just enjoy the
process and i don't really know whether
i'm that much better now sometimes i
look at a video that i made three years
ago and i don't really think i'm that
much better in a way but i know in terms
of what i understand i am better
so i don't know maybe it's a matter of
adjusting one's ambitions
yeah
anyway
okay
good any any questions you have
wow
ah let's see i can't really think of
anything right now isn't that crazy okay
well listen i really appreciate your
active participation at link and the
sort of back and forth between you and
albert and berta on
different items relating to their uh
their content i think it very much
encourages them i think that you know
that obviously these people who create
the content they want some kind of
recognition response
and you always provide that which is
great
right
yeah it's really great i really enjoy it
a lot yeah and i'm really thankful for
the website because i think that i'm the
closest that i've ever been to to
fluency and spanish right
yeah and i saw your video some while ago
you were very good in spanish oh
you're too kind
your pronunciation and fluency i mean it
looked very good to me
thank you yeah
okay
i'm going to head off thank you very
much
and i'll
i'll
send you this first you can have a look
at it and then we'll we'll put it up in
my uh on my uh blog
okay okay thanks angela thank you
bye-bye bye